The word “penny” may have come from the
English ruler Penda, King of Mencia (an Anglo-Saxton
kingdom in today’s English midlands).
During his reign from 626 AD to 655 AD, he
issued coins that were called “pending.”
To further this theory along, the old English
word word for penny is “penige.”
In fact, the Danish still uses the word “Penge”
for their money.
Now, if you think that “penny” came from
the Danish word (not the Danish coming from
the English), then the word could have something
to do with the pans that they used to use
to coin the money.
As with most idioms or sayings, no one is
exactly sure who first said “a penny for
your thoughts” or when.
But we do know in this case who was the first
to publish it and then who popularized it.
In 1522, Sir Thomas More’s book Four Last
Things was published posthumously.
It was a book of meditations on death, God’s
judgement, pain, and how to combat “spiritual
diseases.”
Real uplifting stuff.
In it, it reads,
“As it often happeth that the very face
sheweth the mind walking a pilgrimage, in
such wise that, not without some note and
reproach of such vagrant mind, other folk
suddenly say to them, ‘A penny for your
thought.’”
In other words, a wise man has fallen silent
and in order to garner his wisdom, money is
offered.
The proverb is used in much the same way today.
Despite More’s use, the saying didn’t
seem to gain widespread popularity until after
1547, with a book written by John Heywood.
Heywood is best known as a playwright and
a collector of proverbs.
Born around 1497 (records before the 17th
century are almost always spotty on these
types of dates), he began his career as a
singer in the “Chapel Royal” for Henry
VIII.
His career was going along pretty well, singing,
teaching others to sing, and, occasionally,
acting.
In the 1530s, he started writing “interludes,”
which were essentially what we would call
sketches today – small, one-act plays which
were usually performed within bigger plays.
This is how we began to gain some notoriety.
It didn’t hurt that his interludes were
usually comedic in nature and poked fun at
the very powerful Church (despite his own
devout Catholic ways).
A rather interesting part of this was that
Henry VIII was also a devout Catholic, but
had been excommunicated from the Roman Catholic
Church.
So, Heywood gained favor with the King, but
angered clergymen with his barbs in this rather
divisive political climate.
Either way, in 1546, at the height of his
popularity, he wrote a two hundred page book
entitled A dialogue conteinying the nomber
in effect of all the proverbes in the Englishe
tongue, which would later become known more
simply as The Proverbs and Epigrams of John
Heywood.
Even though the book is named after him, he
never claimed to have made any of these up.
He simply collected them so that they would
be remembered.
As said in the preface of the book, “Rembrying
and confydering what the pyth is, that by
rememberence of these prouerbes male grow.”
Several well-known proverbs show up in this
book include “Rome was not built one day”
and “all that is well ends well.”
It also includes, “penny for your thoughts”
or as written in the book “Freend (quoth
the good man) a peny for your thought.”
Heywood’s political statements within his
interludes came back to bite him a bit when,
in 1547 (only a year after his book), the
ten year old son of Henry VIII, Edward, took
the throne.
With Edward being Protestant, Heywood being
Catholic and taking shots at the Church, he
thought it was safer to flee to Belgium to
live out the rest of his days (which was actually
pretty long – 33 years).
Yes, he was essentially kicked out of England
by a ten year old.
Now, how much was Thomas More or John Heywood
(or any person from 16th century English)
offering when he said he would give a penny
for converting the various neurological electrical
impulses happening in one’s brain into other
electrical impulses that ultimately produce
carefully crafted communicative vibrations
in the air?
Well, according to England’s National Archives
currency convertor, a penny in 1540 would
be worth (accounting for inflation) about
1.6 pounds today.
Converting that into American dollars, that
would be about $2.50, or the price of a McDonald’s
Happy Meal.
So, if someone offers you a penny for your
thoughts, using your newfound knowledge you
can now attempt to extort a McDonald’s Happy
Meal out of them before you talk.
Although for your health’s sake, perhaps
in this case
it would be best just to keep your mouth shut.